welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host death Vader and if you've been
keeping up to date with the channel then
you'll know that a couple of days ago we
released a 21 minute video that sort of
went through a full movie breakdown of
the rise of Skywalker it covered
absolutely everything in the movie from
Cena scene and now I always try to tell
people to take leaks like that with a
pinch of salt
we've just had a brand new scene drop
directly from Disney that pretty much
confirms everything in the leak is true
the new teaser that was released
yesterday shows the entire opening of
the movie and it looks like the leaks
got absolutely everything right even
down to the color of space in it what
we're gonna do in this video is take
segments from a couple of my leaks
breakdowns and play them alongside the
new clip to show you how it lines up
with them in pretty much every way
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything about the movie ruined then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's play the clip with my original
audio okay so the insider said that the
film begins with kylo slaughter of
natives in the redolent woods to get to
Vader's Wayfinder the wayfinder is a
pyramid shaped object that hooks up to
kylos TIE fighter to allow him to see
how to get 2x a goal kylo flies to a red
nebula like section of space to get
there as was seen in recent TV spots for
the movie
kylo passes a giant flowing cube about
30 feet in the air the place is weird
the evil son of solos and takes a lift
down but this is where things go from
weird to insane I mean really insane
Palpatine's voice can be heard claiming
that he made Snoke and that he's been
orchestrating everything from the
shadows so there you have it pretty much
lines of 100% with what was said and
though they cut out some elements of it
from the officially released clip namely
the Snoke scene I think this has been
put in place purely to add some levity
to the release as I have no doubt that
the scene will be way longer in the
cinema now what this confirms to me is
that yep the leaks were true as this was
a scene that's been talked about I'd say
for about a month now it lines up pretty
much with it exactly and
I don't think anyone can argue with it
though I'm sure JJ and Kathleen Kennedy
are smashing the dislike button right
now what this also does is confirm that
the plot league has a lot of accuracy to
it and when you line it up with the
other major clip that we got which is
the the speeder bike chase yeah it looks
like the entire thing's true now this
actually makes me slightly worried for
the movie as normally Studios only
release major clips and scenes like this
when they're also worried too I've
actually had a couple of close friends
who had pre booked tickets to the film
on the opening night and they've ended
up selling theirs after hearing the
leaks and it kind of feels like
everything's just so up up in the air at
the moment with regards to Star Wars and
it's very unclear what's gonna happen
with this movie personally I do think
that it will do well at the box office
because you know it's Star Wars
it's a closing of the trilogy however I
think that reaction to the film will be
pretty negative across the board and
this will cause issues for the IP with
the box office not reaching the full
amount that Disney are really hoping for
if that's the case then I think most
likely that Kathleen Kennedy's head will
be on the chopping block as you know
it's basically her job to make Star Wars
one of Disney's biggest franchises and
if she's not doing a job then there's no
point having her around wells it still
is one of the biggest franchises even if
it under performs I can't see the team
at Disney looking to oust her from the
position and perhaps even put someone
else in place now is Star Wars bad
across the board absolutely not and the
Mandalorian is one of my favorite TV
shows of the air Jedi fallen order was
brilliant and I still have a lot of
goodwill for the franchise in terms of
properties however it just seems like
the movie side is failing massively with
solo barely making its money back the
last Jedi and now what probably is gonna
be the rise of Skywalker I don't really
see how he can put the blame anyone
else's feet maybe
JJ shouldn't have left the first movie
like to me it was kind of like when
Bryan Singer went off to direct Superman
Returns instead of doing a third expert
movie and look what happened there yeah
it's the same thing with Star Wars
either way it is gonna be interesting to
see what happens next we
I do have tickets for their weddings day
midnight showing so I'll be keeping
everyone up to date with how the movie
is so yeah stay lock to the channel for
updates as they come out now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
leaks and if the release of such an
extensive scene has you worried as well
come on below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and if this is piqued your
interest then make sure you check out
our full breakdown of the entire leak
plot which would be linked at the end we
cover everything from the color of the
sky to what games they play so yeah it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know what happens in the movie
ahead of time you want to come chat to
me after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey will head over to my discord
server which would be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the leaks in the comment
section below the one that's gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of December
and the subtle be shipped out from then
Target surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you